[Music]
I only venture at this moment is
reestablishing control over this
continent and every person on it
my allies are gone I'm losing you can
count on the iron bank as soon as the
gold arrives
enough with the clever plans
hey guys new episode just ended and
while we fulfill our expectations as
well as a few predictions and theories
it has also after sanctions once again
in waiting for the next episode in my
next video I will break down the third
episode in details but firstly let's
break down preview for the 4th episode
it starts with Cersei Lannister
revealing her venture which is
reestablishing control over Westeros and
every person on it as it's been expected
the iron bank will play a huge role in
the war between the two Queens later in
review representative of the iron bank
of Braavos promises to Cersei that she
can count on their own bank as soon as
the gold arrives which will not arrive
and therefore the iron bank will not
fund Circe in this war while it might
seem like Cersei will manage to repaid
the debt of the Iron Throne I think we
should reconsider that
Jamin Randall with their armies are
marching back home with a carriages full
of goods full of gold and food lured
from Highgarden
however the spoils of war including gold
with which Cersei will repay the debt
and with which she would basically
persuade the armed bank in the funding
her will never even reach King's Landing
not to mention Cersei
long story short while heading home
Daenerys his army will attack Jaime's
and Randall's army and take an
opportunity to fight them on the open
field as it's been mentioned a few times
for the series Norma can stand a chance
against the track here in the open field
let's say Viserys Targaryen lands with
40,000 Dothraki screamers at his back we
hole up in our castles wise move only a
fool would meet the Dothraki in an open
field and is that is ambush will
obviously result with her victory
Daenerys writing jørgen will lead the
track into huge battle new finalists set
a tough blow for Cersei not only that
sir Civil lost most of Lannister army
but one of her only allies will be
destroyed as well and all spoils contain
a food and goal that should feed their
men and repaid the debt of the crown
will be lost during this battle Randall
and the contrarily are going to get
captured
well Bronn will save Jaime from almost
getting killed her ponder going to
escape in the heat of battle it is it
assumed that Randall is going to be
burnt alive by Danish dragon as a result
of Randall's betrayal over his own house
Tyrell and for pledging his army to
search his cause
Randall's santak entirely on their
handle most likely got a chance to bend
the knee and swear fealty to her because
as the nares said herself in the last
episode the child should not be judged
by the sins of their father and I ask
you not to judge a daughter by the sins
of her father there are also quite a few
shots from Dragonstone in this preview
firstly we have Daenerys accompanied
with a king in the north and their
advisors the mother of dragons is
reconsidering the whole plan of her
conquest over the Seven Kingdoms and is
most probably in that same moment
finally deciding to involve her dragons
in war just as I predicted in my last
video Varys interrupted the meeting
between John and Daenerys by informing
his queen about her ass fleet being
intercepted and destroyed by euron
greyjoy even though I thought verse
would find it out about theos arrival
the shores of Dragonstone thean will
arrive in the following episode then we
have John and Daenerys visiting a mess
mountain of dragonglass on Dragonstone
island now we have the most interesting
shot of Littlefinger pulling out an
elaborate dagger made of Valyrian steel
and the dragon bone hilt
I don't think Baelish is pulling it out
on someone to kill but I do think this
is being favored to the white wedding
theory of mine in Acharya would slit
Littlefinger's throat with this same
dagger and finally after all those years
arias arriving home in the next episode
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next piece
[Music]